good evening everybody
and i'd like to start with a big thank
you to the spectator and spectate
spectator tv for having us this evening
and all of the staff working behind the
scenes to make the alternative
conference
happen my name is john o'connell and i'm
the chief executive of the taxpayers
alliance and i'm delighted to host this
event this evening
we've titled how do we clean up the
state and we saw at the start of the
week that charles moore
and paul daycare were touted for the
chair roles at uh
the bbc and ofcom respectively and
regardless of one's views on their
suitability for those roles at the heart
of that debate
lies the idea that public life is
somewhat unbalanced
that the right tends to win elections
but the left actually run the country
because they dominate institutions
uh is that true in in 2012 the tpa
research found that
of those who declared a political
affiliation five
times more labor appointees found their
ways into public bodies than tories
um and we updated that research earlier
this year and it showed that almost half
declared allegiance to the labor party
compared to less than a third for the
conservatives
so the tpa has led the way on fighting
for diversity of thought in our public
institutions and
furthermore we've long campaigned for a
rationalization of the sprawling quango
state
um so we're going to touch on those
topics and more this evening
we only have half an hour so i'll very
quickly introduce our speakers in the
order in which they'll speak
uh james fraim is the founding partner
of the research firm public first
douglas carswells the former mp for
clapton and the founder of the good
governance project
and madeleine grant is the assistant
comment editor at the daily telegraph
so i'll ask each speaker to set out
their thoughts for around three to four
minutes and then hopefully
if you fire in some q a we'll be able to
get that going to keep the conversation
going for the full half hour
so um as i mentioned i'll go straight
over to you james
thanks very much john and uh thanks to
the spectator for
uh having us all on um
you know it's uh it's a huge question
about whether or not
uh there is balance in the sort of
quangocracy to use one of your words and
what needs to be done about it
i think it's interesting how there's
been
with the floating of charles moore and
orders candidacies
this sort of i mean just a sense of
complete disbelief as if it is
is it possibly one of the jokes coming
out of number ten i mean why would they
ever do such a thing
and i think it's it's as you say we'll
put the
put the merits of the of the
appointments to one side for the moment
but i think it is a
reflection of the fact that people think
that the state ultimately
is sort of owned by the left
that people can't believe for one minute
that you would have people that lean
right
in positions of cultural influence
and i think this is this is generally
true of public life you know you
you have i think you know you you have a
government which has an atc majority
and yet there is a sense sort of
projected i think through
uh much of the media almost as if there
was a coup that they were never voted in
that there was a sort of
illegitimate government which is an
extraordinary
place to be and given they have an 80
seat majority they
entirely politically dominate england
certainly and
and probably england or wales for that
matter
um and yet somehow the the
the center right is is constantly on the
back
foot you know it's constantly there's
this constant sense of
it's it sort of doesn't have any sort of
moral or cultural legitimacy
and you know how do we go about changing
that i i think honestly it's going to be
very hard because
i think even us even our side almost
sort of finds it hard to keep a straight
face when people like
all day crawl charles moore suggested
for these roles it's almost like
you know laughing behind our hands that
we're sort of doing something outrageous
and shocking
and we're really going to stick it to
the left where as you say actually
arguably it's really just about
rebalancing
um cultural institutions so they reflect
the country
more generally again not particularly
talking about daca or charles moore's
people particularly
more the fact that it doesn't seem so
terrible
to have people like that in in in
positions of cultural influence in the
way that we wouldn't be shocked if we
found that
alan russbridger was in the in the in
the running
to to be chairman of the bbc or
something like that so
um i think absolutely there needs to be
a a rebalancing
but it's not just a political rebalance
it's not just political rebalancing i
think there's a rebalancing towards
mainstream opinion across the country by
that i mean
i think we have to and i think to be
fair to the director general of the bbc
is looking at this
there has to be a way of reflecting
mainstream provincial opinion uh from
the you know from the rest of the
country
um in the in the cultural institutions
of this country which anyway no doubt
we'll
explore these things a bit more over the
course of the discussion
james thank you very much um as i
mentioned it's it's quite tight
tight for time so i'll go straight over
to douglas carswell
over the past generation we've seen the
administrative state
um run by what you might call the
blairite ascendancy
and it doesn't really matter who it is
that people vote for
the same sort of people with the same
soft left
prejudice and sometimes not very soft
left end up
running the country and and this means
that
it doesn't often really matter who it is
that the voter votes for
we end up with the same sort of people
presiding over
of a public life and i think we need to
ask some questions
on the center right some strategic
questions as to what we do about this
um it's very easy for us to
um simply see it as a case of musical
chairs amongst
um quangocrats but it has profound
implications for the country if you
allow your
institutions and the institutions of the
state to become the preserve of the soft
left you end up with
institutions that don't reflect public
priorities
institutions that because they're
insulated from public opinion tend to be
i would say
incompetent like the department of
public prosecution
um and institutions that tend to be
quite woke
and we we see the consequences of 30
years of
of the left ascendancy in in our
institutions
when day after day we we hear another
institutional or or or big
uh public body or publicly funded
organization promoting a a
a leftist guardian easter agenda what do
we do about
it well it's easy to say scrap the quan
goes all governments
on the center right tend to say that in
opposition they don't actually tend to
deliver
i think we need to be much more
strategic about using the levers
of prime ministerial patronage we need
to be
we we need to not just sort of tinker um
you know may and cameron were both
utterly useless at promoting
like-minded people i'm not sure that
they knew what was in their mind let
alone
like-minded people's minds so they were
utterly useless at promoting
center-right people to positions of of
influence
um we need to be under boris much much
more strategic it's not just the bbc
it's not just it's it's the the
positions of of
influence at oxford colleges um
right down to the chairman of the
council for widget standards
we need to be really strategic and
ruthless in how we
promote um people um who are like-minded
we also need fundamentally to make the
administrative state properly
accountable
you need to have a system where if you
run a large
quango you and and you use public money
you should be annually accountable as
the head of that organization
for your budget um for non-departmental
public bodies that means that you should
appear annually before the second
community the house of commons and
frankly if you don't get to say so for
your budget
you should be sacked you need that level
of hyper accountability
because ultimately as james knows better
than anyone in this conversation there
are a heck of a lot of people in
provincial england blue collar britain
who i think want to see change and if
boris and his gang don't deliver
far-reaching fundamental change
then you know why bother um we'll end up
with the country being run by the same
sort of blairite cameron ascendancy and
you know they'll just give up
on voting for anyone at all thank you
douglas and we'll go straight over to
madeleine grant from the daily telegraph
great thank you so much for having me um
i mean i share many
of many of the concerns raised by
douglas and james
um but i also i think there is a sort of
a vague dose of optimism i think the
time now is right for the bonfire of the
quangos that
has been promised for so long partly
because i think
in many ways they have responded the
public is under
the pressure of the pandemic the public
has been given a glimpse of just how
ill-equipped and how ineffective many of
these quangos are and that's actually
that scrutiny is quite a departure
because for a long time they've
sort of as it were operating in the
shadows they haven't got
attracted enough media coverage coverage
it's kind of relied on the efforts of
organizations like the tpa to keep the
scrutiny going
they don't haven't attracted much public
interest in a way they've um
benefited from their own banality
because it's simply so hard to
distinguish between so many of these
forgettable acronyms and there are just
so many of them
you know organizations like the tpa have
something of a job on their hands just
keeping track of how many there are so
it's no wonder that reining in
reigning them in has proven difficult um
propped up with public money they lack
all of the kind of checks and balances
of normal politics as douglas was
explaining there's no obvious
metric for measuring their success and
of course they're never exposed to any
of the punishments that would normally
await failed organizations
and companies in the open market um
but as i mentioned the last year in
politics has
exposed many quangos as being incredibly
ineffective and i think in some ways the
public has had a bit of a
brutal awakening um in a way that
for a long time the only people raising
awareness of these things have been
people
on the right of politics with a
particular interest in reforming the
state
so first the electoral commission after
finding leave campaign as innocent of
any wrongdoing on two separate occasions
they then opened a third misguided
investigation into brexiteers
only to be humiliatingly proven wrong
yet again
and then of course the walking car crash
of public health england
um attempted to launch a centralized
testing system which
again proved woefully inadequate and in
some cases
um in their quest for kind of command
and control
at all costs um they shamefully turned
down offers of assistance from
private labs then we had off call on the
fiasco over
exam a level exam grading um and then
it's not quite the quinocracy exactly
but i think it's very symptomatic of
what often goes wrong with the
quangocracy um dido harding
um the ultimate chamocrat um was
appointed to be
the temporary head of the organization
designed to replace public health
england despite presiding over failure
first at talk talk
and then with the government's own track
and trace system so the quangos have had
a very
bad war indeed and i think for the first
time the public is getting a firsthand
glimpse of of
the kind of things that people like the
tpa james and douglas have been warning
off for some time
and failing upwards that sense of the
kind of revolving door which propels
quango kratz from cushy job to cushy job
and then sometimes to oxbridge college
professorships
and so on and so i think there is a a
pretty extraordinary opportunity there
and it coincides with the time when
you know the tories have an 80-seat
majority and they are apparently moving
in the right direction
um with you know axing phe considering
appointing conservatives to key roles in
ofcom and the bbc
um but i'm also seeing some familiar
problems and again it all goes back to
the lack of accountability um i think
perhaps because people
are still not particularly familiar with
the coingocracy
um politicians are still being blamed
for whatever goes wrong
um people don't aren't really aware that
phe was technically in charge of
preparing for the epidemic um the guy in
charge
tends to get the blame so in a way
politicians are kind of
reaping what they sow because for a very
long time
many elected officials preferred to
delegate
important functions to these bodies of
the greater the good and the experts
than actually put in the time themselves
and be fully accountable
but when the chips are down um the
politicians still get blamed for
everything so that sort of takes some of
the urgency away from
uh reforming the quangocracy and the
tory's also playing catch up big time
uh they weren't anything like as active
in uh making public appointment during
during the um the cameron years as label
warren de blair when they were
particularly
prolific um the i saw earlier today that
the
the guys at guido had crunched the
numbers and they found that since 1997
there have only been two years when
tory's got more public appointments than
labour
which is truly astounding when you
consider they've been in charge for a
decade
um so what should we do next i mean
james put it very well he said that you
know
quite fundamentally need to start acting
like a party with an 80-seat majority
and
sort of hold their heads up high and not
be so squeamish about the idea that
these public appointments
uh should legitimately go to
conservatives you know we live in a
country that
voted in 80 seat majority and voted for
brexit and you wouldn't know it from
looking at these
the state of these appointments um i'd
also very much like to have quango
representatives appearing before select
committees annually having to
sit there and squirm and state why they
should continue to receive public funds
it should be
something that is annually accountable
and
um they have to justify themselves
properly um i think more functions of
crango should be devolved to local
authorities um where there is proper
democratic accountability
but i do think i'm sort of perhaps it's
too early to say this but
i'm quietly optimistic i mean i think
you only have to look at the way that
people like
the overreaction of someone like
alistair campbell to the news of the
rumor the rumors of appointments of um
paul daker and charles moore um to see
that i think we are going
um in the right direction um uh
alistair campbell said this country is
run by a right-wing clique in which
appointments like this are made not
according to ability or values but
getting like-minded right dick
right-wingers
to do the dirty work which is uh truly
extraordinary from
the man who presided over so many of
these cronies appointments and so i
think we are
we are on the right track uh but there's
still plenty of work to do
thank you maddie i i'm just going to ask
you the first question off the back of
that actually um
we talk about rebalancing but do you
feel that perhaps
the center right or small c
conservatives whatever however you want
to frame it
we could go too far the other way and
end up stuffing the institutions
with you know um people from that side
of the fence and
you'd actually imbalance it but just in
the other direction
i'm i'm not sure that there's there's
that danger yet
uh certainly not yet um uh i mean as i
say the frenetic reaction of of many on
the left to the these what should be
fairly inoffensive appointments actually
looking at the broad
sweep and thrust of it um i don't see
that danger
if anything i think the bigger danger is
that because um
i think conservatives have often um i'm
what i'm seeing a trend recently is
conservatives are often quite dismissive
of things like humanities degrees and
the arts
um which is i don't i don't agree with
that myself because i think it's very
important that you have
conservatives who are in that world who
can then take up these public
appointments i think if anything the
problem is going to be a shortage of
eligible conservatives who could take up
these roles
thank you douglas could i can i just ask
you so
sorry please go ahead douglas you know
i'm a free-market
classical liberal but i wouldn't want to
see every appointment going to free
market classical liberals i think the
key in
plurality the the reason why public
administration in this country is so
often so bad and so dire is because it's
presided over by people marinating and
groupthink in a lazy
group think what you need to do is you
need to ensure there's a plurality of
opinion
and that doesn't mean you know replacing
the um
cliched thought of the cameron blair
ascendancy
with a new set of cliches from a boris
johnson ascendancy
you need to make sure that you you have
genuine plurality of thought
and where you have groups of experts
appointed to give advice to ministers
you need to make sure that those experts
are competing
in that advisory giving process you need
to allow good ideas to drive out bad
ones that's the key rather than pointing
any any any particular brand or flavor
of
outlook and and douglas just to extend
on something
you mentioned earlier with um uh
quango is going before the relevant
select committee annually to argue for
their budgets um
do you think actually the quango
appointments um
pre their appointment should face a
hearing from the relevant committee or
is that going too far
absolutely i mean there is something at
the moment called um
pre-appointment confirmation hearings
and it's a sort of halfway house because
it's a sort of it's it's not hardwired
into the system across the board for all
um department of state non-departmental
public bodies
it's allowed pretty much i think at the
discretion of
of of ministers but we need a system of
confirmation areas given that the house
of commons has got its act together
and freed the sort of nefarious hand of
the whips in terms of deciding who gets
to sit on the select committees because
there's now
a competitive process to decide who the
chairs of the select committees are as
a competitive process to decide who gets
to sit on the set committees
given that the house of commons has now
got control over the sec committees
we now need to trust the house of
commons select committees
to have the final say over some of these
appointments and frankly that is going
to mean sometimes
tory appointees getting vetted by
majority tory
select committees but that is that's
what happens in a democracy that's what
happens in the united states
that is preferable to what we have at
the moment where frankly some pretty
mediocre people get put into really
important jobs
without people having the opportunity to
to challenge them
and i you know we pay a really heavy
price for this so i
i would give select committees power not
only to
approve the budget of these quangos
annually
but also to confirm the appointments of
those put in charge of them
and and possibly annually to look at um
the the mission of the organization to
prevent mission creep would that be
something they should look at i wouldn't
personally i wouldn't do that personally
i would use the
charter letter system that they have in
australia so that the centre of
government
is mandating each department of state
each cabinet minister with a charter
letter explaining what it is that that
minister is expected to do
and then it's up to the minister to make
sure that the various quangos they
nationally
give direction to fulfill the strategic
priorities
of of of the government in in light of
that charter letter
i i wouldn't involve parliament beyond
controlling the appointment of the chief
of the quango and the annual
confirmation of the budget if you do
that
the rest will fall into life okay thank
you and james i wonder if i could come
back to you
um with your work with public first and
various polling and focus grouping um
to what extent is this a salient issue
with the public and for
and if it's not to what changes need to
be made in order to get them to sit up
and take notice
i think it isn't at all i think the
public have no idea about
the nature of uh the way that they're
run
they have no idea about the relationship
between say
uh tomorrow health the nhs uh
public health england et cetera and it
you know
i wanted to return something that
madeline said at the start really which
is
which is really important which is
um the politicians are held accountable
for the mistakes
of quangos in their space so
you know you had you know during the uh
during the pandemic obviously still
happening you're getting matt hancock
taking heat for stuff that he might say
was the responsibility of public health
england
but matt hancock can't intervene in a
lot of the stuff that they're doing
because he doesn't have
authority to do so and i think it was
you know when obviously a group they've
sort of quangos and they've been growing
for a long time it they obviously
surged uh under labour
and i think politicians thought post the
independent post given the bank of
england independence i
think they thought this was a sort of
clever way of
insulating themselves from a lot of
controversial decisions because they
could say well it wasn't as it was this
independent
quango run by independent experts but as
madeline says when it comes down to it
that doesn't wash with the public i mean
you know when i was
i was director of commons at the dfes
going back nearly 10 years
and the number of quangos that you know
i wanted to get
get control off from a communications
perspective because it was
mistakes going left right and center but
i couldn't touch them
i mean it used to drive us crazy and i
think actually there are too many
quangos
they lots of them should be folded into
their
essentially into their parent
departments so that the politicians who
are accountable
can actually make decisions uh regarding
how they're run
and ultimately so they're not just
hanging left blamed for mistakes which
which
which aren't really their control so all
of these health quangos
i would say fold them back into central
administration and then and then
take a great big sword to them and start
cutting them down to size
but if we're going to have proper
accountability they've got to fold into
the parent departments
that's a really interesting point james
because i suppose part of the perennial
problem with the quango state is that
even when action is taken to
roll up a quango what happens is that
the function itself isn't removed so you
just see
um a set of staff move from one
organization to another
do you feel folding a quango back into a
department just risks
you know bringing the problem back in
house rather than getting rid of the
problem to start with
it does but at least you can do
something about it so you know again
sorry to go on about you know anecdotal
war stories and stuff but you know when
i was at the dfe
i wanted as much folded back into the
department so that i could cut it down
to size because there's nothing worse
when you're in a department you know
particularly like the dfe which is
terribly publicly exposed
you've got these quangos running around
doing stuff that you have absolutely no
control over
no authority over no knowledge about
what the blooming hell they're actually
going to do
um and and in any case as i say
you haven't you haven't or as you rather
as you said you haven't cut down the
size of the state anyway so you've
normally cut down the size of the dfe
but it's just the state sitting off in
alliance that you don't control
so i don't think that it is all of the
sudden sort of growth of departments and
there's sort of regrowth of the state
it's merely bringing greater
accountability that
so you can actually as i say hold it to
account managed it better and ultimately
cut it down to the size it needs to be
right thanks um maddie questions come in
from a
a viewer which is um would
you know putting center right or small c
conservatives into public roles in this
way would it
would it add to this sort of fuel of the
culture war that we're having would it
lead to a widening between left and
right
i'm i think the culture war is here and
it's it's being fought and um
the right the right can't really afford
not to take part um
so no i don't think it would fuel it
anymore i mean it depends if
it depends how you feel about the
culture i suppose if you think it's a
battle worth fighting
i mean i think it is and i think that
the right has to
um or they will lose a lot of what they
hold dear so i think it's
inevitable um i just think that it's
important to
push back in quite a sensible way to
these accusations of cronyism
perhaps by reminding people of the way
that public appointments have
historically tended to go
um using the kind of statistics that i
mentioned from the the
the um the guido fawkes have complied
and of course there's tons and tons of
material on this from the tpa
um i think to remind when you put it in
that kind of context it doesn't look so
croniest after all and they're always
going to be the alistar campbells of
this world who have an interest in
stirring things up and claiming that
something is some
mad right-wing conspiracy um when in
fact it's just
very standard practice and very modest
practice in comparison with
how things have been done um prior to
that
um i mean there are you know there are
cultural um
agitators on both sides who have an
interest in stirring this up but i think
if it can be put into its proper context
you will take some of the toxicity out
of it
okay thank you um douglas um
lots of politicians when they're on the
back benches or in opposition
they talk a good game on a small state
but don't necessarily
you know follow up on that when they
when they win an election or get into
government what
is there anything that we can do to get
back ventures or
or you know people who are talking a
good game to hold their nerve when they
actually get into government
you're so right so often you hear
people who used to be ministers at the
twilight of their
careers particularly on the center right
wishing that they had actually started
to
to change some of the the fundamentals
of apparatus and architecture of
the state to affect change um
you know i i'm an optimist i i
i think that maybe what kovid and the
chronovirus
crisis has done it's it's
demonstrated very visibly to a lot of
people
particularly people in western who are
one step removed from the center of
power the
it's a bit like that that moment in in
the wizard of oz when the curtains drawn
back
we tend to think of these quangos as
being incredibly clever sophisticated
um benevolent organizations but
like the wizard of oz they turn out to
be just a rather confused muddled
middle-aged male
and and i think the extent to which the
quango state
is run by slightly confused befuddled
people who don't really know what
they're doing i think
this is a sea change this i think should
allow
people on the center right to actually
start to talk about deconstructing the
administrative state to actually
wind down entire tranches
of government officials there are whole
swathes
of of government that i think we could
argue now that we could
best do without and i i wonder if one of
the
longer term consequences of this crisis
is that it allows us to popularize the
argument
to rash to ratchet back the the size of
the state
you know um government is not that smart
and i think people can see that
okay um james i i wonder if i could come
to you
and and another finding from some tpa
research we
we obviously looked at the political
affiliations we also looked at the
regional disparity in public
appointments
i suppose a big challenge for a
conservative government is to
try and encourage people from different
areas of the country
to start applying for these roles as
well i mean
do they even know these roles exist and
how can we get successful businessmen
and women from around the
regions to get involved i think
there's one the problems with the
conservative party is it's fundamentally
southern and harsh
and that hasn't really changed and that
remarkable
memoir that was published by um
the brains of these days yeah
i mean you know you you
you know when you end up sort of talking
about the working-class pivot of the
conservative party you can sort of
occasionally convince yourself that it's
happened
really hasn't happened party is still
culturally a million miles away from the
people it represents
and i think that it's going to therefore
be difficult for them to do a provincial
rebalance along the lines that
uh that they ought to be looking at they
just don't they just don't know these
people
so uh you know we've used
madeline douglas and you've used the
word optimism a couple times
i'm not optimistic about things at all
i'm very pessimistic
um i think that time is is rapidly
elapsing during this parliament
and uh i think you know before we know
it we're going to be
a year out from an election uh
and the party hasn't really undertaken
the sort of necessarily cultural shift
that it needs to take so
uh i would like to end on a moment of
darkness and uh
that's where i'll leave it for me no
that's not like you james at all
um just to finish um quite often
discussions about cuancos it sometimes
reminds me of regulations everyone knows
that they're bad but they can't name a
bad one
um douglas what quangos do you think
could be
for the chop the electoral commission
would be first
in the firing line we don't need it it's
a waste of time in fact it
undermines democracy it's bad for
democracy the charity commission is a
monstrosity it actually inhibits
civic society doing charitable deeds
and one thing that really annoys me is
when conservatives point out that
they've appointed a so-called
national tory to preside over these
institutions that just legitimizes
the socialist agenda of these these
bodies
i'd get rid of them um i would get rid
of you know
a a whole tranche of of government
quangos but i would
start with the charity commission and
the electoral commission and you know
what
if the leftist state wants to come out
and defend the work of those bodies
i i think that's a battle we could we
could win
i think we could um look at some of the
the payroll costs of the people who
preside over those organizations
look at some of their dismal record um
and their misjudgments and their
miscalculations
and i think that's a battle we could
easily win and easily popularize
thank you and maddie do you think um
broadcasters are a problem in this
i.e you know the bbc or do they do do
they take
a quango view as the expert view and
that's it yeah i think they do i think
there's a big
inherent bias towards statism and
towards top-down
methods of dealing with problems and it
simply because the bbc i think part of
the problem is that they're so
it's um it's partly it's a bit like i
suppose what james was saying about the
tory party being southern and posh i
think the bbc is quite
uh liberal metropolitan and they all
kind of think the same way
regardless of where they come from in
the country and they
the idea of the alternative viewpoint
simply hasn't occurred occurred to them
because they're so rarely exposed to it
and it's very hard to correct your bias
if you're not aware of it in the first
place
so that presents a massive problem at
the bbc
and i've noticed this a lot in how
they've been covering the pandemic when
questioning ministers the interviewer
will often say things like
but if that you know this lockdown
doesn't work if this local lockdown
doesn't work
uh are you gonna ramp it up a bit like
the assumption being that
working is if it's not working you
should do more of it you know the idea
that that might not be a good solution
in the first place just doesn't occur to
them and i think that's a product of
not having enough people of that
worldview who work there in the first
place
okay thank you very much um
unfortunately we've run out of time we
could talk about this
um well for at least another half hour
if not more but um
again i'd like to thank the spectator
for having the taxpayers alliance on and
our guests this evening for for joining
us too um
as it's been mentioned a couple of times
this is um an area of um
research for the tpa over many years
we've we've
aimed to expose um the extent to which
public appointments are skewed one way
and and indeed to expose the size and
cost
of the quango state and we've got some
more work coming up on it
and very very shortly so thank you again
to our guests thank you to
spectator and sign up to receive our
updates at taxpayersalliance.com thank
you very much
you